>> I CAN YT I CAHEAR YOUKAE.
MUCFO HUIN
E DEPTH OF THE PAIN WE FEEL
CONNOT BE WH
AND HOW IS EVERYBODY THI
WH DSTOW? UM,CK HEARTBRT OF
LE--KEUPIFUL
HINING, CHILDREN
BICYCLES,ITTLE
LE BASEBALL, PEOPLE GOIN
OU -
PLE.PLE SHOT IN ROINDY TAKING
ND A
CO TRAVELED FROM
THREE HOURS AWAY WITTHE
EXILL OPTHOWN
COY.
'S
>> MAYOR, OUTY.
LAW
MOMENTS AGO OFPODIUM,
SURROUNDED BY LAW ENFOEMS TALKIH
THAT -- THAT YOU ARE A PERIEN A
THAT YO, THAT YOUR
FREQUENTS, AND THAT SOMEE
PEOPLE THAT WE SLI T WONDERINGF
THOSE FOE, AND PERHAPS HOW
SECURITOFR NG IF THEY WTO MAK
THAT YOU UH,
HE I
KNEWIMWELL.MEONE THATVEEL
EN THE SHOOTER.RS INOFFICER, AN
DID EXCHANGE GUNFIREOOR R WADYCT
WITHSTAND THATD KILLEDLIEUTENANA
WHO TRIED TO PTE
AND IN THE PROCESS, LOST HIS OWN
LIFE.OTHER ONE OF THE VICTIMS O
RETIERIS H
D INPED TOT
MAETGOOU
SUAR
HESORY
COMMISSION
HAFO
D EN WE SAW HIM, UD T ON, AND
MOTHEROOK FOR HIS
R. MAYOR, W ARE YOISING?IDN'T G
SLLAHT AT  -- UH -REALLY, WAS UL
VE PCE
WE ARE ALLN PAINIS
COMMY.
AMM
FROMS FFTH
NAPEOPLE TOW  -- INTERNATIONALL.
'RE NGMU
NOWN ACI NEIGHBO
WE'RE A LOVINI. WL OU
LO
ILL STAND TOGETHER WILL D
WIS.
CONTROL,NN LIKE HIS COUNSHSENSIN
WMAKERS IN L
UH, HA SPEECH
LTO COMEO  END.
THE GOVERNOR OE STATEW
YORK -- KATH -- SPOKE LY ABOUT
FOCUSED ONH OF
E AC
THATD
INUF MORO CAIGNORE
THE VERY OBVIOUS INDICATIONS
THAT THIS A .
T WHO
YOARE FIRST K HOOD, DE
BUFFO'ND I AW EEL
>> T'SR THAT, OUR COIS NO TYP
HATE, THAT TY TO TCOO PREMEDITAR
LL
F  VIOSSHIS C
OO SAW DAY --
M AE IN THI
RAL.
THIS TYWAPCES IN THIS
SADLY , IN THIS
PE HADACCESS TGUNS TACTICAT  TH
OF B MAYOR, YOU MENTWMAKERS HAV
INSTANCES LIKE THIS.
TALK TO US A WHAT HAS E THE STA
IS ANDIBLLAW
BUFFALO AN.
FERA
AG CITY OALO,LAENRKA COTI
INVESTIGATION,HI
TH THEY COD. SLLW
EVERY LEVEL THAT HAS BEE
WOG AROUND CLOCK, AN
WORKTOE ALOF
THE RMTHIG, WE AO LAT.
VERY THANKFUL TO T
RESPONSE OF THE BUFFALLIPARTMEN.
IFORHENSE  MORE LIVELY
LOST
PERSO
SIBLY COULD, SWERCEMENW ENFORCER
FORMATION AND